they have no audience nobody watches
they'll take anything they can get
they're they are so desperate for
attention and I imagine there's probably
some executive or somebody associated
with the Grammys and they're sitting
there saying like guys
we lost 60 of our viewers we're dead in
the water what do we do and they were
like people aren't going to want to
watch shows like this we need
controversy we need to piss people off
and here's the hope get a bunch of
conservatives angry and at the very
least you will rescue a liberal audience
so they start posting stuff like this
hoping that shows like this generate
rage but not that we will watch it that
the tribalists in the cult will say well
we're big fans of the Grammys and then
they will start endorsing it and the
Machine will then prop up the Grammys